foreign
[Music]
Harbor in Southern California
an Oceanfront playground that attracts
throngs of tourists and locals
it's this ideal location that Drew Mikey
michelados and his wife Lynn to open a
Greek restaurant just Steps From the
water
hello welcome to the Greek from day one
when we opened the restaurant in 1994 it
was a success oh my gosh it's really
good we did great it was always busy
already guys let's starting
my dad he had that old school Greek work
mentality just go go go go and the
kitchen was always running very smoothly
I need a large pen because I'm going to
cook some onion I felt my American dream
come through make me feel like very
successful very very good
But as time went on my dad's standards
have dropped okay I gotta complaint okay
guys they said the captains were rock
hard he's been working 365 days a year
for 17 years he's just burning out from
being here so long it was rubbery what
do you need a robbery
I don't know there's no robbery monkey I
mean he hardly anymore he's making sure
that everything is cooked to Perfection
that's not good the person when I see
our level drop because the standards are
not high enough I'm done
he came out of the cafeteria Mike he's
really let a lot of things slip through
the cracks the calamari was really
really I tasted the calamine it was good
well it's not like it okay and that's
why our businesses declined
not very many people around the
situation is frustrating but I want to
change this place I want to make it
better I haven't learned everything but
I will I know I can I'm very capable and
I know I can make it better than ever
my dad has a hard time listening to
other people sometimes because this is
what he created but I'm here to help I
mean he wants to make sure I'm 100 ready
but I can't be 100 ready if he doesn't
allow me to be I need your help
Eris is a super creative person
he's a great Entertainer great people
person
but at the same time how are you gonna
help her run a restaurant if you don't
know the kitchen
to run this restaurant you have to come
back here at this kitchen and Aries do
not have done this before
[Music]
this restaurant is not only my father's
Legacy it's all of our Legacy we've all
worked together and I've seen the profit
pretty much diminished until it's been
non-existent how much money do we have
in our account right now we're getting
low we're getting low I don't know how
I'm gonna do this
it's like we work our asses off and we
don't make any money it's
hard
oh my God I'm just hoping that Chef
Ramsay will help us get this restaurant
to be the success it deserves to be
I don't want what we've spent years
building up
I just don't want that to happen
[Music]
wow look at this place absolutely
stunning on the water it's almost like a
little slice of the Mediterranean I'm
fairly busy as well how on Earth can a
restaurant fail in this spot dying to
find out what's been going on
[Music]
the water
hello
well hello how are you I'm excellent
first name is yeah Lynn Lynn Gordon nice
to see you um owner yeah brilliant
you're running with your husband
this is our son Hello nice to meet you
good to see you I'm not sure why don't
you get your father let's sit down have
a catch up I'm really happy to see Chef
Ramsay and I hope he's pretty nice to my
voice
not too nice
okay
um I am very happy to be here B I'm
dying to find out what's wrong with the
place How could a restaurant not work
when it's sat on the water
[Music]
nice okay mum uh 17 years it was very
successful and we did very very well so
when did it start to turn the last
couple of years not profitable yeah wow
okay
um and health do you hear when I work 14
hours a day seven days a week but seven
days a week yeah that's the truth
serious
crazy it is crazy he's been doing it too
long he's burnt down and he might not
admit it but he is are you downtown no
no no you're gonna sit in that kitchen
till you drop I mean where's the
succession
is the goal to groom Iris will take over
or
no no
well I'm here and I'm doing all the a
lot of stuff right now I mean sure do
you work in the kitchen I don't but
that's one of my goals I want to learn
the kitchen it's one of my I'm glad
you're here because I want to learn more
stuff and do you teach him how to cook
no ready why
thank you
is he not good enough
are you that much of a control freak no
no
no
no is he not committed I feel like I'm
pulling teeth in my mind I expect him to
be more here than he was so he's not
committed he
shouldn't he never
heard that I would
I'm here he's trying to save this place
and it's just are you committed now I am
committed here I am you are yes I am
[Music]
I understand like yeah I haven't been
here at times but I need Chef Ramsey to
prove to my dad that I'm ready to do
whatever it takes to make this place run
better and smoothly and it's time for
big changes this is the time
so how would you write your food out of
10 what would you give us my food I give
it 10 10. yes right let me eat let me uh
get the grips good to see you nice to
meet you likewise Adam okay all the
recipes that I have for the Greek food
came from Greece a lot of people when
they visit Greece they come here and
they tell me the food is better here
than Greece I think San Francisco is
going to like my food yes
foreign
so you know everything everything first
the calamari the calamari is Gonna Be
Heaven what's going to be how exactly
[ __ ] okay let's try the calamari okay
and you know what I'll have the uh Hot
Stuff the platter the platter okay and
I'll take the cold Patcher as well I'd
like to see that I want to see as much
as possible oh okay anything else I'll
have the masaka okay yeah with the beef
Brilliance I think we're done thank you
I'm very excited San Francis
he needs to see when the food is not
good everything is not good
calamari appetizing make it
hit the olive oil and put onions and
bell peppers with the wine you guys do
what I say Mike is a very proud person
he does not take criticism well that
Jeff Ramsey is here to help he's not
here to compliment
s why would you cover them
full tablecloths
the deck always hideous I haven't seen
chairs like this
since the bankrupt 30 years ago my
grandma's 80th
is that a disco ball about Saturday
Night Fever
in fact it's like there's two disco
balls up there what's going on I'm just
like going back to 1970.
okay that that's like a lemon okay and
we're looking to heaven or hell
oh dear and this is our Coldplay okay
great thank you thank you
looks like I'm having a hell day right
yeah it's not yeah it's not it's not
good yeah
can I take it away quickly I know
stop it yeah very popular
that's a strange looking hummus
seriously hello is there any way to do
that is this sure
seriously
Greek dips it looks like six plates of
Greek dog [ __ ] that's what it goes in
like imagine what it's going to come out
like my game
is the most important
I mean you have to be really idiot to
make the hummus watery
[Music]
this is our hot sampler wow okay Jesus
[Music]
meatballs are cold in the middle
Falafel look like they're being sat on
my [ __ ] Greek goddess yeah no on the
fillet paste a lot of filo paste but
hardly anything in them yeah they're
greasy very shiny yeah no good and
they're terrible there's no filling in
there thank you thank you
a taste of Greece yeah Taste of greasy
[Music]
what the [ __ ] is that what is that this
is
[Music]
for The Roasted uh potatoes okay great
thank you thank you enjoy it
[Music]
[Music]
the dragon is shocking so bad
Dreadful
Dimitri the eggplant is spongy and raw
you're having the musaka yeah disgusting
carrots and mush that is an insult to
any Greek aisle listen can you get me
all the chefs in the kitchen out of the
Island so I'd like to meet them
okay guys all of the books he won them
over there he went all the cooks
everybody
Falafel sex to me it wasn't a good I saw
some of my food is not the way he was
describing the food that
was a disaster I mean I've just sat down
and had the biggest [ __ ]
embarrassment to Greece that I've ever
tasted in my entire life the platter
Bland Falafel dry on the biggest kick in
my Greek gohanas
liquid hummus
hummus cooked bitter it's an insult not
just a grease but to the vegetable
itself did anyone taste it of course
it's wrong
it's done wrong come on that's
frightening what hurts me is the fact
that you're actually realizing that it's
[ __ ] and still sending it I can't do
anything about it
I'm Greek I grew up with this suit but
I'm not allowed to cook the food the way
I'm cooked in Greece here I'm following
my kids way and he's tired Mikey have
you given up no you run your business
like you've given up no no it's not true
I don't believe that my food is that
terrible okay my food is similar
kefalonia you think it's similar to
Catalonia yes sir yeah not today my
friend your calamari is greasy it's
bland
how come I have all these people says my
calama is the best I ever have the
blowing smoke up your ass you're not
that stupid no one at your 12 thousands
of people no stop exaggerating where are
the thousands of people that tell you
that your calamari is the best are they
booked in for dinner tonight
[Music]
came from Greece
bring it over you make it better here
you've made it worse
I get really upset when Seth Rams has
talked to me like that I know how their
food is and the people love it and it
has no clue about the food here
[Music]
foreign
and as the restaurant fills up with
diners are you ready
Chef Ramsay is anxious to begin his
kitchen investigation during dinner
service so what are you doing service
how do you work what
I do here
[Music]
to watch a new expedites I do if I have
to wow what are the TOs systems POS it's
right here Marika Marika there's my
daughter right there hello Hi how are
you nice to meet you my wife good to see
you too I think Chef Ramsey doesn't know
what he's stepping into my dad is just
like really set in his ways
and what's that for just the minced
onions and this is Veggie domadas what's
under here baked carrots
plenty hell we cook them today so it's
sort of like a cafeteria or everything
all the carrots done and all on bunmery
there's a lot that we hook and then
store it and just take out whatever is
for the order each order that's not good
but I'm not letting the kitchen so I
don't really have a saying over that
it's always cooked it's cooking right
now yeah no it's not cooking it's cooked
yeah we're cooking food and it's it's
sitting there drying out it's all cooked
it's a [ __ ] it doesn't look like a
cafeteria to you no God bless California
[Music]
with so much of the food prepared in
advance you happy with that yes this
restaurant has no problem sending dishes
out at a rapid Pace hey about 10 table
15 table 91 please ready
calamari chicken caesar salad
this food normally come out this quick
lately yeah it's like sort of flying out
okay it's ready take it take it oh my
gosh Mikey you're not tell them anything
you're saying to the chefs what do you
want me to say
all right let's keep going everything
all right back here get out
[Music]
it's just ridiculous like I'm not trying
to stop you I'm trying to help you but
my dad he gets so egotistical about it
sometimes it's like I'm this just little
eight-year-old getting barked at
your orange yeah yeah I just need to
cool off after that
I don't know I can see the tension
your thought was there Expediting the
food letting it go Source tripping all
over the side and it's almost like he's
given up I mean was he like that 10
years ago no I I think he's just
physically exhausted and he's been
working 15 hours a day his whole life I
mean imagine that do you ever sit down
and say dad you know it's so obvious
where we're going wrong and I want to
help but he doesn't want to listen he's
so stubborn man
I don't know man it's just
it's just horrific this has turned out
to be a very funny Greek restaurant a
little bit different to what I expected
[Music]
unfortunately for the diners the
restaurant is also different from what
they expected
out more and they were still raw oh God
as Trey this is cold after Trey the lamb
chops are supposed to be rare after Trey
gets sent back to the kitchen oh my God
unbelievably there's almost as much food
coming back as there is going out
Dad how you doing don't bother me go
dance go dance
the situation is frustrating obviously
we have problems with this restaurant
but I don't know what to do exactly you
ready huh yeah I'll announce it right
now
hello everybody Welcome to the Greek at
the harbor my name is Eris uh we're
going to perform a little dancing for
you right now so please enjoy the show
there's more dances to come
[Music]
back
[Applause]
what's that collecting going on a Greek
dancing and the belly dancing and really
yeah
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
despite Eris pleasing some of the diners
with his dancing
far from pleased with the food
the batter on the fish and chips was
still slimy the rose lamb was inedible
give me Aries please oh and they said
all of it was lukewarm where's Mike what
is it just smell that it's not inside
there inside what's wrong with that eat
a little bit I'm not eating nice smell
good it's what it's good you're sick
Mike you're sick man I'm very worried
about Mikey because it should be obvious
when something's not cooked properly
there's no way that you can say oh well
they were just complainers it's real
Harris you need to know what's going on
here as well as far as your father's
concerned it's good there's nothing
wrong with it let's try yourself he's
not even a chef and he knows it's dried
come on Mike you stood down and watch
that [ __ ] come out it's an embarrassment
to Catalonia
I knew this was going to happen my dad
he's not stupid he's a great cook but he
also isn't denial bit he's the type of
person like asking for help maybe is a
sense of failure to him
my emotions are deeply hurt
from what Seth Ramsay says
you were just relaxing yeah it was just
really sad you know he's just an older
man that
can't really handle it all
I love you
I just don't like it when my dad is so
sad
[Music]
it's an hour and a half into dinner
service they don't like any of it and
even though food is flooding back to the
kitchen you stood down and watched that
[ __ ] come out it's an embarrassment to
Catalonia Mikey seems to have lost
interest
it's almost like he doesn't it's just
what do you want me to say I don't feel
good wearing Seafood tell me about my
yeah
what's happening I don't know but why
are you doing this to yourself what do
you want me to do I want you to wake up
a little bit you're letting it happen
under your nose what are you I'm just
saying I'm sorry to be a little bit more
[ __ ] honest with yourself and never
lie okay but how come you haven't taught
Harris anything how come you haven't
done by your side why haven't you
treated him like a son what is it none
of things
Something's Happened and you better tell
me what
I don't know what happened
I don't know yes you do
I don't have to say nothing I don't
think don't act like that you can't just
give up come on
how we doing
no we're not doing well we're not doing
well it has to be a little bit more
honest with us I'm not honest no you're
paying the price for it I don't
understand why you're not closer to your
father I don't understand why you're not
open with that big Greek heart of yours
I I I don't get it it's time to change
you know
it's going to need a commitment from you
a commitment and his father's son and if
you've got any chance of carrying on
this Legacy then you need to be by his
side you won't teach me if anything it
doesn't make sense
have a word with him have a word I'm
struggling
[ __ ] me
I didn't sit down man
tired
I don't want you to struggle here
anymore
I'm fine dad
just let me let me let me help
let me help you I want you to be ready I
told you that before us I know it was my
dad even though he loves me I love him
it's just it's almost like I'm not good
enough for him
it's a shitty feeling it hurts
I love you
[Music]
Gordon is still completely mystified by
Mikey's lack of mentoring of heiress
we've got two minutes we'll catch him
okay please Annie is only one other
person to turn to for answers
so I'd love to hear from you you know
why have they been ignoring each other
well when heiress went to college he
never really wanted to be here and most
of the time he wouldn't be here at all
he'd come like at night to dance and so
forth and when he graduated from college
we had his party here so we had I mean
the place was full we had 100 people
here so and when he was doing his little
speech and thanking people for coming
and everything you know he announced
I'm gonna make something of my life I'm
not working in the restaurant what in
front of all the staff in front of all
of his friends
wow I mean how rude you paid the fees
for the college he comes back and hosts
the party in his parents restaurants and
then shits on them from a great height
I remember that very well yeah that was
as if what we've done all these years
was like uh worthless
is Mikey sort of hers do you think he
still holds it against him yeah does he
yeah it's he really does
unbelievable
it hurt most
very bad
I've always remembered it I've never
disgusted never talked about it
but it hurt
[Music]
s
Gordon has finally learned the real
truth behind what's tearing this family
apart he announced I'm gonna make
something in my life I'm not working in
the restaurant what
and now Mike and Eris arrive at the
restaurant unaware of what he has just
uncovered place to sit down
I want to tell you something really
important
I'm [ __ ] up with you and I'll tell you
why I don't think that you've quite
understood the level of support that
you've had in and out of here and so
when you turn around and told all your
friends and your parents restaurant that
you're going to make something out
yourself almost in a way that you are
disgusted with being brought up in a
restaurant and this wasn't you you were
above that
well it wasn't me being above it it was
just I didn't know if it was the way you
declared it wasn't good enough for you
well this was before I know yes but you
did it and you chat on your own doorstep
I wasn't sitting on that I love my
family
well I was I was confused at the time
too I didn't know what I was going to do
with my life I went to college I didn't
know if the restaurant business was
something I was going to do and I didn't
know if I was ready to do it but I don't
think you've ever understood the
ramifications of a announcement like
that how did you feel truthy about that
statement truth my son when I say
something like that it hurts me yeah
thank you
I mean I I'm not perfect look at me no
I'm just saying no no if you've got
anything to say yeah I'd say to your mum
and dad
take the opportunity to give a little
bit of privacy
I
[Music]
I just see how we struggle as a family
regardless if we're making money or not
we we kill ourselves here and I didn't
want to kill myself either not in a
selfish way I just didn't want to I
don't
but I guess I remember it because it
really hurt me when you said it I
remember it and I don't think there's
anything that we've ever talked about
and I sincerely apologize for saying
that because that was so wrong of me
um Dad I'm sorry
yeah
love you too I think Mikey hasn't really
taken era seriously because he's never
really gotten himself committed but that
has changed and for him to make this
declaration with such passion he's
definitely committed I 100 believe that
everything's gonna work
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
cleared the air with his parents Chef
Ramsay is still concerned about his
commitment okay
so I've been doing some thinking why are
you hung around so long it's my family
it's like I don't we don't give up on a
family and this is my my home too so I
love this place and I want to fix it but
I don't know if you're committed enough
that's all because it's not about
dancing on the dance floor no I know but
if you put that determination that you
put on that [ __ ] Dance Floor last
night carrying all those [ __ ] tables
in your mouth in the kitchen trust me
you'll be Untouchable here that's what I
want I know at one point I wouldn't
believe in me either I've changed I know
I can do this I just need support and I
just need my dad to help me
so you say you're committed I am
committed yes and you say that you're
committed yes yes so put both your hands
together
let go comes out
now
oh [ __ ] yep even if I'm right-handed
don't care I don't care because you're
not cooking you're gonna be taught
now look at me
for the very first time in the history
of Father and Son get into that kitchen
and show him something I don't care if
it's a simple Greek salad a roasted
fresh or whether it's a stunning hummus
I don't care but show him
yeah now
why don't pull me too much now don't be
a bull getting handcuffed was a funny
experience I'm gonna need a plate to put
it in all right we're about to walk with
you my dad kind of like this bull trying
to attract me let's make a pasta you
want pasta this is exactly what I've
been looking for to have this
opportunity so let's do it okay slice a
tomato yeah I can do it
how's that good okay let's put the
onions
[Music]
I'm gonna wait on the garlic right yeah
if it cooks faster any seasonings that
we put in or anything let's put some
black pepper a little sprinkle yeah you
want me to add some of the sauce yeah
cooking with my dad was great reducing a
little bit and then we're done it really
alleviated a lot of tension and I'm
proving them right now I'm gonna learn
the kitchen and I guess the only way you
could ever learn is just to do it right
yes it was your finger
it's pretty good huh there you go tastes
Greek
totally it was a lot of fun for me and
Harris to be that way and I see that
Aries I said passionate about this
restaurant and I'm very proud Gordon we
got it done
what is that Greek pasta did you listen
to your father I did yeah
how is that oh yeah it's nice I've seen
more consistency in this plane than I
did in the whole of service last night
it did my heart good because this was a
turning point this was the first time
that Mikey has ever really shown aerith
any Greek cooking thank you I have very
strong feelings about my boy that he's
not a boy any longer he's a man and I'm
ready to back off a little out of the
way his way are you committed to do it
of course
what I know I would teach you everything
okay okay so that's what I want
foreign
now that it appears as though Mikey is
finally passing the torch to aerys Chef
Ramsay and his team move ahead with the
restaurant makeover
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
ready for a stunning new change yeah
good
today we are saying goodbye to the Past
and opening the doors to your new future
ready to see a restaurant off you go go
and go in
wow
welcome to the new Greek wow wow
stunning nice it's amazing wow it's so
beautiful it's so beautiful when I first
walked in here I saw a banquet hall with
Hideous chairs that was set up with no
charm so we've taken a tacky restaurant
out of the 80s and put it into the 21st
century and the good news is the disco
balls have gone look at the ceiling
you've got the Greek windmills oh look
at that have a look at those beautiful
tables they were covered before we got
them sanded we got them varnished
they're your own tables excellent gone
are the murals why have a mural of a
harbor on the wall when you're sat in
front of the harbor and look at that
baby down there on the wall a
custom-made Greek flag shutter wow
beautiful
shutter wow this is outstanding complete
Joy is what I feel right now
wow oh Jesus how are you huh wow I have
a goosebab on me feels totally like
where I am now in Santorini on the hill
there feels like home it's pretty it's
particularly beautiful Mikey I'd like to
see if their lives like this aren't you
happy yes yeah I think this is one of
your best so decorations I've ever seen
like this yes I agree I think it's one
of the best also
to go along with a dramatic makeover
come down
is an equally dramatic redesign of the
menu okay let's have a look at the menu
the dips Tzatziki the hummus beautiful
not smeared on a plate not sipped
through a straw and a proper dip fluffle
look at them small dainty delicious and
made with a spicy chickpea nice gyro
it's a homemade Pate okay wait to taste
it you've got the grilled lamb chop a
server Grilled artichoke Sunday Tomatoes
yeah Aruba salad and tazini sauce the
zucchini eggplant moussaka layered with
potatoes topped with Bechamel a little
bit of chili in there so we've got some
heat in there as well at the same time
excited oh yeah this is the best I ever
seen in my life it's fresh it's taken
part of what you put into this
restaurant to begin with and we've
modernized it that's all you did great
yeah yes okay I want you all to dig in
all right have a little taste Okay jump
in
oh my God it's amazing excellent at the
beginning actually I was I was was
denial about the food but this is the
best food I ever have Greek food so good
the waffle is gone melts in your mouth
not dry the food's really really good I
mean it's amazing and it's a new
Direction it's new beginning and I'm
excited about it this is really tastes
good it's really good
with the reins of the restaurant being
handed over from father to son okay
Mikey hi you ready you ready yeah Chef
Ramsay is Mikey working the salad
station and heiress in The crucial role
of the expediter you ready yes okay
girls you don't take [ __ ] from them yeah
and you're the last [ __ ] line of
defense don't let them throw food out at
you we have a new menu in line awesome
new recipes I'm taking charge of this
kitchen I want to make sure people are
following the recipes and they're not
[ __ ] them up make me proud boys let's
do this
hello word of the relaunches spread and
the restaurant fills up quickly with
eager diners
[Music]
would be great okay
my kitchen needs to be driven let's go
all right First Take It Up Guys two
vegetarian Musa cars fire those right
away okay I know let me count zucchini
musakas please areas is in charge of the
kitchen tonight but he has to step up
and and do this I got the hummus you
guys got the musakas how much time two
and a half minutes nice all right
another
got it how much time will that calamari
two minutes two minutes let's do it
cheers that's what I want to hear push
and encourage push and encourage yeah
it's a vegetarian Musa
in spite of it being his first time
Expediting Kathy you're up to come right
back Harris is looking very comfortable
four minutes on the saganaki watch the
Falafel and a steady stream of orders
are flowing out of the kitchen
calamari and the results are unanimous
back in the kitchen under the watchful
eye of Chef Ramsay what's the sauce for
Less in there next time yeah I don't
want to piss you down the side yes
heiress continues to perform
I'd rather stop okay I'll [ __ ] go
crazy at them
let's go to table 11 here now ready
yes I got one more spot in the comforter
right all right Kelsey you got another
Brazil another Fisherman's catch here
there you go all right who's this for
caffeine just take it it's your turn is
that cooks all right
stone cold it's raw stop stop stop stop
it's relaunch night Harris's big chance
to finally prove himself guys let's get
it together we got it come on but just
when it appears as though everything is
on track who's this for Kathy just take
it the kitchen is starting to unravel is
that cooks
look at me if they're out of control and
you're out of control we're finished
because you are maintaining the
standards hey hey all of you stop one
two three four five you come here come
here come here look at what you're
sending out that wasn't like the first
table
[Music]
I'm not sending that and what the [ __ ]
is that
come on guys mush look at me you have to
stay in control you've got to stay in
control okay yes that can't let the
kitchen fall apart I'll do whatever it
takes to get better let's slow it down
slow down slow down thank you kick it at
a time standards
all right table 32 how we looking and
where's the fisherman's catch gotta want
to see [ __ ] go out guys come on make
sure it's cooked and good all right a
very determined heiress clearly has his
Focus back this chicken said you're too
[ __ ] long finally he's catching
mistakes
that you asked for
[ __ ] cold in the center guys come on
and quickly getting them fixed almost
you're gonna have to reheat this let's
get that done before we continue guys
make sure it's quality listen to him
there stop throwing food well spotted
look at me this is transition this is it
yes okay guys this is a team effort all
right you guys with me yes okay good you
guys got it okay come on good that's
what I want to hear
awesome Ozzy take this keep it going you
guys we need a little bit more sauce on
that meat nice I need one more calamari
guys coming thank you
fire the chicken fire the lamb chops
yeah let's focus on table 25 and table
30. doing good can you believe that's
just something no oh what's the price a
little bit but Ayers did a great job for
the first time Expediting just wipe it
down I'm very proud of myself
[Music]
oh my gosh no how do you guys like the
new menu
it's awesome good but I loved it not one
complaint I just need the lamb burger
and we're done coming up now
let's finish this [ __ ] come on Eric is
totally in control of the line
Expediting and table by table by table
he's stepped up so good it was good and
that's a fabulous feeling
no that was awesome
thank you
well done seriously well done we had an
excellent relaunch yes we had our bums
but my god there was an amazing buzz in
there tonight a dramatic change yes yeah
customers love the food yeah not the
decor but the big transformation tonight
was Iris
you nailed it you did a phenomenal job
thank you I've never seen anyone and I
really mean this take to Expediting the
way you did tonight that was your first
time and it felt like you've been doing
it for 10 years Mikey how was that for
you to listen to him controlling the
kitchen yeah he did a great job it's
very impressive
Seth Ramsey came and reunite us together
my son at night would be very successful
I believe that stay together as a family
because when it works it's beautiful of
course this family right here we're
unbreakable thank you stay in there I
will yeah look after him thank you very
much because of Chef Ramsay my dad
Believes In Me and he knows I can do
anything I have a lot of work to do
personally to learn the kitchen but I'm
an ambitious young man and I'm ready to
do it you've got the win in the sale run
with it okay thanks again good night
thank you Gordon
wow when I first arrived this restaurant
was a big fat Greek mess we made a lot
of changes some dramatic changes to the
food the decor but more importantly to
Aries and now that guy has his feet
firmly on the ground this restaurant has
every chance of not becoming a great
tragedy
[Music]
what the [ __ ] was he doing with those
tables
[Music]
in the days that followed Eris continued
to embrace his role as leader of the
kitchen go ahead take that out three's
next guys I need a feature and is
determined to maintain the high
standards that Chef Ramsay put in place
hey the fish is wrong guys watch the
fish with heiress in complete control
and new customers packing the restaurant
on a nightly basis I love it Mikey is
considering doing something he thought
he would never do it's good to chase
yeah it has to be done retire Mikey is
so proud of bears we all are he's really
proof that he's committed to make this
restaurant be the best it can be fries
let's do it Chef Ramsey thank you so
much Eric this future is definitely
bright and so is the Greeks great job I
love you
[Music]
foreign